good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight ever been to
buckhead in atlanta it's a beautiful
residential
partly commercial neighborhood in the
northwest corner of the city
it's not a huge place fewer than 80 000
people live there but it's fair to say
that without
buckhead atlanta at least as it's
currently run couldn't exist
taxes from buckhead residents account
for fully a fifth of atlanta's entire
city budget
so you'd think the people who run the
city would be very polite to buckhead
they certainly
should be but the opposite is true for
decades various mayors of atlanta have
attacked buckhead as if there's
something offensive or immoral about
maintaining a clean and orderly
neighborhood
for the most part the residents of
bucket have taken this abuse in silence
complaining seemed impolite
so they've continued to send huge
amounts of money to a city government
that hates them
for politicians in atlanta it has been a
very good deal attack
buckhead then take the doe but that deal
could soon be ending
and the reason for that is the current
mayor a spectacular mediocrity with
unusual
high self-esteem called kisho lance
bottoms
like so many big city mayors bottoms is
an incompetent demagogue she has no idea
what she's doing but she's willing to
say
anything for a while that was tolerable
to the people of buckhead like most
people who live in cities
they know the drill they're used to it
but then last summer
things changed a man called rayshard
brooks was shot to death in a parking
lot at wendy's by an atlanta police
officer
brooks was apparently drunk had fallen
asleep in his car in the drive-through
lane
when police tried to arrest him brooks
went berserk we showed you the video at
the time it's painful to watch
brooks stole a cop's taser and pointed
at him that's when an officer called
garrett wolf
shot rayshard brooks it was a sad story
but it was
understandable once you watch the tape
and you thought about it carefully
but kesha lance bottoms didn't wait to
think about it carefully or at all
without pausing for an investigation she
immediately fired officer wolf
and then she issued a predictably
self-righteous press release about it
an independent board later found that
what bottoms did was illegal but by then
it was too late
hundreds of atlanta police officers had
already left the force and those who
stayed
understood very well that there was no
point in making arrests
who'd want to be officer wolf nobody
so response times plummeted you call the
police
they didn't come crime soared criminals
found that even when they'd been
arrested for
violent crimes they were back on the
street within days
can you guess what happened next here's
what happened next
eliana kovich and her boyfriend were
shocked to learn the man in this video
who is accused of attacking them
was out on bond the couple was outside
of the mercedes-benz
dealership in buckhead last june when
they say a man started to threaten them
he took out his knife that he had in his
pocket
and he said he had a gun he kept telling
us that he was going to kill us
kovich says the violent word soon turned
physical
came around the other side of the car
punched
my boyfriend in his like left temple and
then
he punched me and then he punched me
again
and i fell to the ground i like blacked
out the suspect fakradovian moore was
arrested and charged with seven felonies
for the attack
however he was released on bond five
months later and azkovich and her
boyfriend did some digging they learned
moore had been arrested just days before
in clayton county
for misdemeanor battery charges
and then was released and then while he
was out on
bail from clayton county that's when he
attacked us
it's pretty unbelievable threatened to
kill them punched a woman in the face
what'd they do wrong exactly
nothing just down the street in buckhead
in buckhead murders year to date are
up almost 50 percent that's a lot of new
dead people robberies and aggravated
assaults are up by nearly 40 percent
car thefts 65 rise
lennox square mall in buckhead was one
of the first indoor shopping malls in
the united states it was a great and
famous place now it's too dangerous to
visit beginning last year someone was
getting shot at them all virtually every
month
in december of 2019 a macy's employee
was shot during a robbery
in january a man trying to defend
himself for armed robbery
was inadvertently shot by a cop in
february of last year a drug deal led to
a gun battle outside of bloomingdale
in march a dispute over a parking space
outside the cheesecake factory led to
more gunfire
which killed someone and so on so people
in buckhead just stopped going to that
mall
ultimately authorities decided they
needed security and metal detectors they
put police dogs throughout the buildings
they set up a network of security
cameras with software to detect firearms
it seemed like it would work but it
didn't there was just too much violence
this past april a gunman beat a 60 year
old woman next to her car in the mall's
parking lot and then stole her purse
elena police later said that somehow
none of their cameras had caught the
crime
a witness called james glass says he
never saw any police officers or
security during the assault
even though the attacker took his time
beating the woman because he was
enjoying it so much
according to glass quote it seemed like
he was celebrating what he had done
he started to rejoice and started
shouting just like he was happy for what
he had done to this lady
it's disgusting and it's still going on
on monday two 15 year olds shot and
nearly killed a security guard at the
apple store atlantic square mall
so if criminals can terrorize the mall
in buckhead which is now one of the most
surveilled places in the entire city
what can they do to a neighborhood well
they can terrorize it and they are
they're attacking people on residential
streets in buckhead
watch this report from fox 5 in atlanta
neighbors say they're shocked after two
crimes hit their buckhead neighborhood
atlanta police say on saturday they
found a man with a gunshot wound on west
wesley road
investigators say the man and two others
were shot at while jogging hours later
on saturday atlanta police responded to
the collier ridge apartment complex
police say they found a man who was
severely injured on scene
he did in fact strike a individual that
was taken out trash
atlanta police say they arrested the
suspect shortly after that crime
now investigators are working to figure
out a possible motive
the man who was shot jogging on saturday
is called andrew wuerl you should know
there's no back story here he didn't
know the guy who shot him he wasn't
doing anything he was just jogging on
the weekend like a good citizen
and a guy pulled up and opened fire why
his 9-1-1 call is difficult to listen to
but you should listen to it just so you
can understand precisely what keisha
bonhams
has done to buckhead here's the call
help help hello collin
1211 where's wesley is this the house
department our places
i'm on the street 1211 wes leslie i got
shot
is the assailant still nearby no i
didn't no he drove away
okay and it's very serious bleeding
yes i'm bleeding i've been shot
and he was shot twice something similar
happened to a woman called valerie
casper on a trail in brookhaven right
near buckhead she was stabbed four times
in the back by a total stranger in broad
daylight as she was walking on a trail
casper was pregnant with her second
child at the time
she was forced to deliver her baby more
than three months early
because she was stabbed by a stranger
why was she stabbed why was underworld
shot these weren't robberies the only
point was physical injury was terror was
brutality
the victims appear to have been chosen
purely for how they look
but don't call these hate crimes it's
not allowed you can't say that
privately though many people in buckhead
suspect that's exactly what's going on
they've been attacked by reckless
politicians for years
politicians have ginned up hatred of
buckhead for political reasons
so why wouldn't others take them
seriously why wouldn't shootings and
stabbings be the end result of that
some people in buckhead have had enough
of this they don't think it's going to
get better
two bills currently in the georgia state
legislature would allow buckhead to
leave the city of atlanta then run its
own
competent police department and resume
being a safe nice place
cnn for one hates this idea cnn is
headquarters in atlanta and has been for
40 years they know exactly what's going
on in the city
they don't care you don't like getting
shot while jogging well then you're a
racist
the mostly white neighborhood a buckhead
is pushing to separate from the rest of
the city
cnn's ryan young has more from atlanta
the buckhead exploratory committee
reports they've raised over a half a
million dollars and is now pushing state
lawmakers to push through a bill
that would allow their city hood
petition to be voted on in the next
election
the predominantly white neighborhoods
movement is gaining traction with
republican lawmakers
oh are you following this did you get
the dog whistles mostly white
predominantly white
got it so if you're opposed to getting
murdered outside cheesecake factory
you're a white supremacist
they always say that here's the funny
thing they don't mean it
how do we know they don't mean it take a
look at how they live
how many cnn anchors including the ones
you just saw have weekend homes anywhere
near section 8 housing
let's see we'll check our notes here
right around zero in fact not
one instead they run to martha's
vineyard or they charter helicopters to
fly to the hamptons on friday afternoon
in other words in their spare time they
get as far away from diversity as they
possibly can not just some of them
all of them every one of them that's the
truest generalization
ever made a recent piece to put a finer
point out of the new york post
describes how many rich liberals from
new york have flooded into the poor
unsuspecting state of montana
bill gates has been camping out in big
sky recently a lot of them have
why it's not the fly fishing bill gates
couldn't cast a fly rod if his fortune
depended on it no it's not that
the appeal is the monochromatic
neighbors outside of the indian
reservations
montana has the demographics of 1956
america everyone looks the same it is
not a melting pot
so no rich liberals don't actually
believe that diversity
is our strength they hate it so much at
the first sign of spray paint they run
for the widest hills they can find
then they lecture you some more about
how you're the racist because you don't
like getting shot outside cheesecake
factory that's how it works
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else